[Music]
if you retired could you like create a
day that would be just fine for you
yeah like what would you do okay I wake
up in the morning okay think of
practicing right yeah yeah well I have
the scenario I'm ready for the thing go
ahead first of all I wake up in the
morning papers take me two hours that's
right okay that's right breakfast well
ours is already day long you got the
same two hours all right
oh and I just learned how to swim right
at an adult age right right so now I go
swimming right now
I don't shame on your parents for not
teaching you everything I was worse than
that I fell in a pool and I almost
drowned my mother would never let me go
near a pool or a giant lady yeah yeah
she just like no chance right so you
hired a guy to teach you to swim I know
I met a guy in France an 85 year old guy
who taught Charlie Chaplin kidding and
the guy was able to get you to swim and
in one day in one day within within two
hours I was and you were comfortable I
was a person who didn't know how to
breathe in the shower right okay this
guy in two hours had me at the bottom of
the pool was foot on my back okay so you
read the paper
yeah I swear now we go to the pool
friend I go for a walk with my wife
because we live on the beach what I do
with my wife I like to walk we walk to
the couple um how long is that walk at
for an hour an hour an hour and a half
so we killed two hours a day for five
hours
all right and we haven't eaten lunch yet
or you know it's lunch it's lunch right
have a nice lunch dad have a great lunch
go ahead so far I'm we lunch is my big
meal Ryan then after the lunch got taken
that a nap okay
nothing better than perhaps like an hour
so now it's four o'clock
my wife's English is tea time go ahead
oh I like that that's good so now we
have tea go ahead and biscuits and the
whole thing awesome told it so you know
then a little CNN everybody we would
kind of go our own way a little bit
before you know it's better friends come
over I have dinner and then in bed by
what 9:00 they in bed by 10 o'clock BB
make sure to never dumped you it's like
what had a nice silly
she could be doing what she could be
doin she be having tea at 4 o'clock